on compte malheureusement des deux côtés
du côté israélien du côté palestinien
les morts encore aujourd'hui deuxième
semaine de ce conflit qui a repris de la
vigueur
reportage et ensuite nous parlons à
daniel levy le consulat général d'israël
à montréal et aruba ghazal député de
québec solidaire d'origine palestinienne
reportage d'abord israël continue de
mener ses frappes dans la bande de gaza
seulement la mort et la destruction
ce restaurant a été bombardé tout comme
cette usine où l'on fabriquait des
éponges des routes sont éventrées dans
des quartiers densément peuplés
les bombardements ont étaient incessants
la nuit dernière raconte ce résident au
moins 200 palestiniens sont morts depuis
que le conflit a éclaté lundi dernier le
hamas contrôle la bande de gaza se dit
prêt à un cessez-le-feu
si israël suspend ses attaques nous
demandons à la communauté internationale
d'intervenir pour mettre fin à l'
agression a déclaré le premier ministre
palestinien
mais de son côté israël indique que son
intervention militaire se poursuivra
aussi longtemps que nécessaire pour
rétablir le calme dans son territoire
l'état hébreu a reçu plus de 3000
requête palestinienne qui ont fait 10
morts
il ne compte pas baisser les bras nous
allons continuer de frapper les cibles
terroristes dit benyamin netanyahu au
lendemain d'une réunion du conseil de
sécurité des nations unies qui a échoué
à rapprocher les deux cas washington
leur demande de mettre fin aux
hostilités tout en réitérant que son
allié israël a le droit de se défendre
contre les attaques terroristes
le secrétaire d'état américain a réclamé
des éclaircissements sur le bombardement
de l'immeuble qui abritait la chaîne al
jazeera et l' agence de presse
américaine associée de presse israël a
justifié cette frappe en disant que le
hamas ils menaient des activités de
renseignement n'ai aucune preuve
concrète n'a été donné par la chine je
n'ai pas reçu d'informations
additionnelles dit anthony blinken
les etats unis affirment qu'ils
poursuivent leurs efforts diplomatiques
pour mettre fin au conflit qui ne montre
aucun signe d'apaisement pour le moment
ici olivier bachar radio canada bon rien
on parlera donc à la députée rumba
ghazal d'origine palestinienne dans une
seconde mais avec nous alignant direct
avait de lévis consul général d'israël à
montréal monsieur lévy bonsoir je les
vis est ce qu'il ya des appels à la
désescalade depuis une semaine
israël dit continue à dire votre premier
mineur on va continuer et avec toute la
robustesse possible jusqu'à ta queue
jusqu'à jusqu'à quelle limite justement
combien de marc devra-t-on compter mais
seront un nouveau voyage des cui lundi
dernière les organisations terroristes
islamistes qui contrôlent le gaz là
continuent à tirer des missiles vers le
centre la population civile
en israël on peut pas continuer à vivre
comme ça il faut arrêter les auteurs il
faut complètement détruire les capacités
militaires du hamas
mais qu'est ce que ça veut dire détruire
la capacité militaire du hamas
qu'est ce que ça veut dire jusqu'où êtes
vous prêt à aller nous sont pas prêts à
continuer à vivre comme ça ça fait déjà
vingt ans vingt ans que les
organisations terroristes tirent des
missiles de gaza vers les centres
populations civiles en israël on peut
pas donner commencent les clés aux
calmes dans la région il faut arrêter
ramasse il faut détruire
et ça infrastructures militaires qu'ils
ont construits dans le bond de gaza vous
venez de parler d un tunnel qui coûte 7
milliards $ dont le vent de gaza il ya
un sa structure des tunnels pour la
machine de guerre du hamas douzaine de
kilomètres vous pouvez imaginer combien
d'argent de cammas vient de dépenser
saut cette infrastructure
aucun missile iranien il lance l'état
d'israël mais monsieur lévy en fin de
semaine par exemple la tour qui abritait
la télévision al jazira a été la cible
est votre premier sadi c'était même une
cible légitime dans ce que vous appelez
le recours à la force nécessaire parce
que vous êtes attaqués par le hamas vous
faites des victimes innocentes vous
faites d une tour qui abrite des
journalistes est ce que vraiment un est
rendu là dont le tour y avait aucun
blessé aucun mot la réalité est que le
hamas se cachent derrière des
journalistes derrière les médecins
derrière les enfants et derrière les
femmes il commis un crime de guerre
double parce que chaque et missiles
qu'il tire vers l'état d'israël c'est un
crime de guerre mais en même temps ils
utilisent les citoyens palestiniens
comme boucliers humains
tout ça a été relancée suite à une
tension à jérusalem est où il a une
famille de palestiniens des familles de
palestiniens qui étaient monastique sont
menacés d'expulsion par des colons
israéliens
on revient on n'a pas le temps de tout
refaire l'histoire de ce conflit là qui
malheureusement renaît
régulièrement mais dans quelle mesure
tant qu'il n'y aura pas de solution le
statut cours va amener une tension
grandissante sur le terrain en selle on
voit d'ailleurs dans des villes
israéliennes en des arabes des citoyens
arabes les citoyens israéliens
les manifestations près de la mosquée à
jérusalem est ce ce pourrissement alors
comment y faire face d'après vous vous
savez et des baux il y à des disputes
civile sur le propriétaire
il y en a un moral il y en a au monde
entier dans ce cas là il ya quelques
locataires qui refusent de foyers leurs
lots noyelles donc c'est un cas civile
l'état d'israël un jeu ne pas à côté de
ces procès et je n'arrive pas à
comprendre comment on peut justifier une
guerre régionale à cause de quelques
quatre locataires refusent de payer le
loyer et en plus et c'est vrai que en
israël il ya des jours est très rude de
tension et mais vous savez chaque chaque
pays un mot fort de périodes de tension
mais les lumières de tats-unis ici à
montréal il ya 50 ans il y avait des
tensions
ça c'est le vrai fils d'une démocratie
et je suis sûr de la démocratie
italienne ou pas gagné oui mais monsieur
lévy en termine à on a l'impression que
la d'ailleurs la colonisation se
poursuit par les colons juifs on a
l'impression pour peut-être voir la
carte quetin que vous aurez tout le
territoire et que ça sera totalement
assurée et qu'on aura chassé les
palestiniens il n'y aura pas dans votre
esprit de paix je voudrais vous rappeler
que israël a quitté la bande de gaza
entièrement à 2005
c'est le hamas qui contrôlent le bande
de gaza et malheureusement ils ont
détruit tout leurs infrastructures et là
bas et la vie là-bas c'est vraiment
enfer et malheureusement l'autorité et
palestiniens qui est complètement
corrompu refuse toujours à négocier avec
l'état d'israël est arrivé à un accord
de paix compréhensif je peux vous
assurer c'est le peuple d'israël et les
gouvernements et d'israël est tout à
fait prêt à et résumés et les renouveler
le processus de paix est rentré à la
salle des négociations
arrivés à un accord de paix compréhensif
avec deux états pour le moment il ya un
état palestinien en bande de gaza et en
croisière et palestiniennes ou certaines
en soutenant la solution de deux états
malheureusement c'est la question qui
refuse d'accepter l'existence de l'état
d'israël
en même temps vous devez vous ai dit que
il ya encore de paix avec l'égypte avec
le jour denis avec les émirats avec
maarten avec soudain avec le maroc et je
suis sûr que nous verrons bientôt autres
pays arabes qui vont jouer processus de
rapprochement avec l'état d'israël parce
que les gros menace de la région c'est
par israël et l'iran
d'accord lignes à court terme syrie en
irak et autre bande de gaza à très court
terme monsieur lévy donc il n'y aura pas
de cessez-le-feu dans les prochaines
heures
votre compréhension tant qu'art à une
roquette qui est temps que des requêtes
seront lancés vers israël
à court terme il faut arrêter les
missiles au moyen terme
il faut trouver un mécanisme comment
démonter les sept organisations
terroristes djihadistes qui contrôle la
bande de gaza lorsqu on ne peut pas
continuer comme ça et au long terme il
faut rentrer en négociation arrivé à
court de piste de corps de fait pendant
compétitive très bien on vers un site de
notre vivant on aura devant nous un vrai
accord de paix daniel levy conçu davie
de lévis et consulat général d'israël à
montréal merci beaucoup merci madame un
diesel et la rumba ghazal est avec nous
des petites merci de québec solidaire
merci d'être avec nous d'origine
palestinienne vous êtes né à beyrouth en
gaza
comment où vous en êtes dans l'analyse
de ce qui se passe vous avez entendu
vous entendez régulièrement l'argument
des gens du trail en disant on se fait
attaquer le hamas est une organisation
terroriste on n'arrive pas à cohabiter
où vous en êtes dans ce qui se passe
écoutez moi ce qui m'importe le plus
comme beaucoup de québécois comme
beaucoup de gens dans le monde c'est que
le drame humain qu'on voit devant nous à
rêves que dix enfants
c'est le cas des décès jusqu'à
maintenant on sait que demain on va se
réveiller il faut avoir d'autres morts
d'autres blessés et des gens marqués à
vie
c'est un drame humain qui se déroule
devant nos yeux et n'importe qui qui a
un coeur à la bonne place veut que ça
arrête
et au delà de la géopolitique au-delà de
l'histoire qui dure depuis très très
longtemps kim si l'histoire de ma
famille mon ma famille a était réfugié
en 1948 mes grands parents ils ont vécu
au liban comme réfugié aujourd'hui moi
je me retrouve ici mais cette histoire
là est extrêmement marquante c'est sûr
que moi elle va me marquer
particulièrement parce que je suis
d'origine palestinienne
mais c'est un drame humain ici à ce
niveau là qu'il faut le ramener
parce que la situation politique essaie
de la résoudre c'est extrêmement
compliqué à mettre ce traitement qui en
même temps ça donne des munitions
c'est le cas de le dire à israël quand
le hamas tire des roquettes vers israël
et vous vous l'avez dit d'ailleurs vous
n'êtes pas d'accord avec la stratégie du
hamas qui attaquent israël
je ne serai jamais d'accord peu importe
d'où ça vient avec la stratégie de la
violence jamais et la hamas et les
toutous les représentants des
palestiniens le taux de personnes
soutenons ne servent pas leur population
il ne l'est certes au lieu même où
disait on peux m'imposer sellers et lui
il n'y a même pas eu d'élections qui ont
été enlevés depuis 15 ans aux mêmes lois
organiques donc si donc vu que les
populations civiles et même aux siens
israël les populations civiles ont le
droit de vivre en paix ce qui n'est pas
le cas en ce moment
donc ce n'est pas en se frappant en
frappant soit des roquettes ou des
missiles on est capable de compter les
roquettes du hamas
on est incapable de compter tout ce que
l'île et de l'aviation aérienne ou
ce que les lits l'israël lance sur gaza
parce que si des dizaines de fois plus
et ça fait beaucoup plus de dommages
donc il faut que la communauté
internationale cesse de faire juste des
balbutiements du bout des lèvres en
disant avec faudrait peut-être arrêter
il faut qu'il y ait des sanctions et moi
je suis la population moi j'ai été à une
manifestation samedi et les gens
manifester de façon pacifique en disant
on veut que nos populations fassent
pression sur israël et il n'y a pas
d'autre moyen de le faire pour qu'elle
arrête parce que si ces pratiques qui
causent le plus de de violence mais il
n'y a pas d'autres moyens tant pas en
envoyer des communiqués en mettant en
place des sanctions ne pas leur vendre
des armes et caetera une campagne
internationale qui existe en ce moment
il faudrait que le canada l'appui bds
boycott désinvestissement sanctions
comme on l'a fait en afrique du sud l'an
pour elle ça fait bizarre israël et
vis-à-vis le le morcellement de
l'autorité politique militaire des
palestiniens vis-à-vis des agissements
du hamas ont fait quoi parce que pour
qu'est un dialogue du fauquet deux
parties oui qu'il en ce moment les deux
parties vers l'autre partie
palestinienne les politiciens comme je
vous ai y sont ils savent pas très bien
leurs peuples innocents en prison
quant à eux aussi donc là on est face à
une situation où c'est une impasse si on
fait rien et on fait juste envoyer des
communes équipées on n'arrive pas à
s'entendre sur le prix unique et la
résolution mais il ya des gens encore si
on voit les images moi j'en regarde
depuis plusieurs semaines sur les
réseaux sociaux
je dis n'importe qui qui incarne on
serait tous dans la rue en train de dire
qu'il faut que ça arrête donc se lancer
des blancs ça ne réglera rien il faut
que l'on soit ferme en condamnant ce qui
se passe et tu composes des gestes parce
que l'ifrap israël et il ya cause
énormément d'impact beaucoup plus que de
l'autre côté donc là il faut que quelqu
un arrêt et après ça il faut que les
esprits se calment et qu'il y ait des
discussions
sinon je ne vois pas d'autres solutions
possibles est-ce que
madame gaza vous êtes quand même pas
découragé de voir que on revient à la
même chose l'on revient on revient ça
faisait un bout de temps ça va pas été
aussi violent mais quand même parce que
je le disais à monsieur lévy parce que
le statu quo amène les mêmes problèmes
là on n'est pas arrivé à dénouer et
l'état serait le prix sa place là il le
plus de place possible et de l'autre
côté les palestiniens n'ont jamais
réussi à chasser les éléments plus
terroriste alors vous n'êtes pas
découragé de voir ce cercle vicieux
c'est sûr que les gens qui regardent ils
disent mon dieu ça dure ça dure ça dure
et anonyme
il faut jamais dire c'est norman qu'est
ce que vous voulez c'est comme ça ça
fait soixante treize ans mon ma
grand-mère à la 89 ans elle habite ici
mais depuis quelques années et elle a
des seize en 1948 quand elle est
expulsée elle a vécu au liban elle a
vécu toute la guerre dont une survivante
qui est ici et la mémoire vive de cette
histoire là et c'est sûr que c'est
décourageant si quelqu'un avait une
solution on la mérite tout de suite mais
où au delà des solutions politiques
c'est vraiment ce drame humain il ya des
actions qu'on peut poser
ne serait ce que par humanité pour que
ça arrête et ça pourrait durer comme ça
s'entend si on continue à toujours faire
les mêmes choses
il ya une solution qui existe comme je
vous le disais d'imposer des sanctions
il faut que ce soit israël parce que
c'est eux qui ont le qui sont la forte
qui ont la cds a remis 100 du monde ça
c'est un fait et pour que après ça il ya
des discussions mais moi je ne suis pas
une experte
non non je suis mal deuxième c'est pour
choisir je voulais avoir l'écho du pas
qu'un citoyen québécoise d'origine
palestinienne et je continuerai à parler
de votre grand mère qui voit tout ça
on lui parlera un jour ça doit sait
quelque chose
l'histoire de ce pays là de ce coin tu
proches rien c'est qu'il ya quelque
chose d'hallucinant parce que on revient
toujours à la même chose
rumba ghazal merci beaucoup député de
mercier de québec solidaire vous avez
une grosse fin de semaine vous vous
allez peut-être changé oui le chef ou de
porte parole où on va parler de ce rodéo
panel politique dans une second merci
beaucoup
j'écouterai plus merci merci au revoir